Adam Levine performs an emotional  tribute to the late christina grimmie  god I loved her so much I'm talking to  you guys I miss her  it's unfair that she's not here on  Tuesdays episode of The Voice the late  singer's family was there to announce  the creation of the christina grimmie  foundation christina was on Team Adam  and a finalist during season six of the  competition show her former coach and  friend got choked up ahead of his  performance with his current team in her  honor I'm gonna be singing every word to  her  [Music]  you can start to  Christina was tragically shot and killed  in June of last year signing autographs  after one of her concerts